hi Dan how are you hey doing good day
appreciate you taking my call sure
what's up no okay what happened is my
siblings and I we recently received an
inheritance from a great aunt and one of
our family members is feeling entitled
to some of the money just to be clear my
wife and I we've had some time to digest
it and we know that the money was
clearly given to us and it's something
that we need to properly manage as a
family we are wanting to despite how
everything's going we are wanting to
gift
some of the money over to the family
member that is feeling entitlement to it
but what I really need advice on is I
want to ensure that when we move forward
and we go ahead and do this
I want closure sometimes going to get
money emotion and misbehavior happening
in the background we want to do it in
such a way where it turns to be a
blessing not something that's going to
cause future issue and so was it the
things they have have rights to this
money what happened was many years ago
my if the individual was on the will and
it's my dad and he was going through
bankruptcy divorce all that kind of
stuff so the agreement was with the aunt
was that my brother was going to be put
in place of my dad and what happened was
she could ended up putting all three of
our names on like myself my sister and
my brother and when my dad went back to
talk with her and say Kay well we're
through the bankruptcy with her all this
stuff can we put me back on
she said no we're leaving it as it is
okay and so I that's where that so she
already told him no why does he feel
entitled I don't know I don't either
and I don't know how you reward that
entitlement mentality with a gift I I'm
struggling with that that was not your
aunt's intent and yet you're gonna give
him money anyway and in the middle of
that his attitude sucks
yes so um I I question whether you're
caving great so that's what's in the
background here's the thing someone
that's entitled the entitlement is so
illogical yeah that that there that
there is no there's not enough
safeguards you can put in place that
won't keep them from being entitled
later I mean they'll show up on your
doorstep later and say they're entitled
to your you know I want your car I'm
entitled to that because I raised you
yeah they just make up crap you know
once somebody has no boundaries of
what's really theirs or what they have
rights to which is entitlement then
there's really no stopping them and I
don't know how giving him money is going
I don't know how you can put a guide or
a boundary with this money that's that
he's going to respect because entitled
people don't respect boundaries right so
I don't think you're going to get that I
think what you're going to get is
resentment that you didn't give it all
to him yep and then I think later you're
gonna wish you hadn't done this okay
because I think I think you're in other
words I you you think by giving him some
of the money
maybe he'll calm down I think the
opposites gonna happen because anybody
that's this freaking arrogant when his
aunt looked him in his two eyes and said
no I'm not gonna put you on the will
your three kids are getting it instead
then he feels like he's entitled it was
her money it's not his he's not entitled
in any way so I I mean I I think you're
probably gonna cause more problems by
giving him money not less that's just an
opinion this is the Dave Ramsey show